c'est le meilleur cyril ans merci à
thomas hugues duboscq qui m'appelle je
réponds bah oui mon francky d'amour
texto à l'antenne mon chéri métis ta
santé je suis 22 heures sur 24 à long
terme
maintenant je prends les gens
directement du sérail je parle à mes
potes a aussi un ça va mais chéri
d'amour
je voudrais juste et radio j'ai appelé
j'ai envoyé un sms hier à franck et à
plein de potes pour une association pour
les hôpitaux et franck a répondu tout de
suite et je suis sûr qu'ils m'appellent
pour ça que je veux en être
et c'est encore une fois voilà on voit à
voir en famille en amoureux avec les
émotions parce que je leur avais demandé
de donner un lot il répond toujours
présent moi il m'a fait un geste
barrière franck magnifique bernard
montiel 10-q répond toujours présent et
que tu lui as fait un geste
marié à barrière également des monts
franck juste mon chéri je voulais juste
dire deux petites choses quand même
parce qu'on à l'antenne on en gagne un
tu sais que j'ai vu cent fois ton
dernier film parce que c'est le film
préféré de mes enfants chez deux heures
voilà donc voilà donc le seul s'il ya
une seule scène qui vous êtes et une
idole joaillier c'est normal amo phoque
j'espère qu'on aura l'occasion de passer
quelques jours de vacances ensemble
voilà mon chéri je t'embrasse mon bébé
je t'embrasse pour aimer d'amour ça les
mots seuls les gardiens d'espoir
l'association
voilà on en avait parlé la dernière fois
et franck voilà franck dubosc injure
c'est tellement un à mu delek mais je la
vends plaisant c'est un mec c voilà que
je le vois c'est que franck du losc
c'est une barrière parce que parfois je
passe du temps avec lui fin du mois ça
veut dire que je l'attend dans la
voiture il va acheter un truc au
supermarché
ça veut dire qu'il va parler avec tout
le supermarché pendant une heure écoutez
l'avis de tous c'est comme ça aussi ça
va mal et hyper saint louis
bah c'est bon les mecs me franck et
daniel dont moi c'est également